observemos como el precio de una opción
varía y se relaciona con respecto a su
fecha de expiración y comparemos dos
opciones del mismo subyacente digamos
que es una acción que sería de una
compañía de electricidad y el precio va
siendo el mismo en varias ocasiones
excepto que uno de ellos tendrá un mayor
precio pues su fecha de vencimiento será
más lejana
entonces comparemos comparemos esta
opción de compra que está aquí que es
una opción de compra de la compañía de
electricidad que tiene un precio de
ejercicio de 17 dólares y su expiración
es en el 2011 si es en el tercer viernes
de abril abril 2011 y la vamos a
comparar con la opción que tiene el
mismo precio de ejercicio pero que se
vende se vence en diciembre de 2011 así
que el precio de ejercicio de ambas es
de 17 dólares pero al comparar estas
opciones una de éstas tienen mayor costo
por su tiempo de expiración ahora vamos
a checar los precios aquí de este lado
el precio fue de 3 dólares con 25
centavos y si me voy del otro lado te
darás cuenta que el precio fue de 2
dólares con 36 centavos
a qué se debe esto como lo había
mencionado esa la diferencia de fechas
una es por ocho meses más entonces ahora
me voy a ir a la gráfica y vamos a
suponer que el derecho en la gráfica de
los 17 dólares se encuentra justo aquí
aquí están los 17 dólares esto dibujando
hipotéticamente los 17 dólares y bien
sabemos que tienes la opción o la
elección de adquirir cualquiera de las
dos opciones y digamos que estas
acciones se comportan así y el precio
que trazamos por acá abajo es el derecho
que te da al tener alguna de estas dos
opciones y si eres el propietario de
alguna de estas dos tienes el derecho de
comprar las acciones en 17 dólares y
después venderlas al precio que tú
quieras tal vez el precio que estoy
marcando aquí se vean como unos
veintitantos dólares entonces si te das
cuenta ahí que tendrías ganancias pero
ahora si tuvieras la opción cercana al
vencimiento hablando de la del mes de
abril tú lo que tendrías que hacer o lo
que te convendría ahora mismo sería
ejercer la y ya cerrar el trato de la
opción para que si tuvieras ganancias y
si fuera la de la larga fecha de
expiración no hay
pues más adelante podría llevar a cabo
el mismo procedimiento anterior que se
llevó en el mes de abril para checar si
las acciones continuarían subiendo y a
ti te convenga porque también hay que
considerar el caso de cuando ya bajan y
hay alguien más con otras opciones fuera
y llevan ventaja en esto pues el que
tiene la fecha más próxima de expiración
es el que puede hacer que la tuya
continúe o no y esto nos llevaría a
estar por completo fuera de lo ideal
pues la opción no tendría valor en esa
fecha y así que si tenemos la opción con
fecha de lejana de expiración que sea la
de diciembre de 2011 lo que podemos es
seguir obteniendo la o seguir
conservando la y tal vez esperar que las
acciones sigan subiendo que sí tengan un
buen movimiento pues hizo un tanto
probable que esto pase quizás en un muy
buen día en el mercado y se puede hacer
de una forma limpia inclusive teniendo
esta situación con la fecha lejana de
expiración la de diciembre de 2011 y
sientes que no es momento de ejercerla
porque hay alguien que puede llevar
mayor ventaja al hacer esto en el futuro
así que lo que puedes hacer
ejercerla ahora y venderla en esa fecha
futura para que justo ahí se obtenga
algún tipo de ganancia